be the first to see Everest the way it
is meant to be seen one week early in
imax 3d visit imax com to get your
tickets now human beings simply aren't
built to function at the cruising
altitude of a 747 our bodies will be
literally dying can we get you up to the
top down to the bottom before that
happens you all right good the star of
the movie is Mount Everest it's sort of
part of all of our imaginations whether
we've ever even seen it or heard of it
or been on it ourselves today's a day
huh I wanted to achieve big epic movie
moments from that mountain I see you the
way you haven't had the chance to see it
it's a big scale moving so that means
you got to get an app or I means you
gotta shoot in the mountains you need
real weather and snow there's a lot
there giving you the sense of adventure
good good back oh oh it's gonna be
transporting them into not only a happy
key planet landscape but also an
emotionally epic landscape which is what
you want any film of this kind of size
let's go to do
okay you do that you meet you hey it is
so out land is up there it's so crazy
and that's why we wanted to do this in
3d as well to be able to almost feel
like you did go up the mountain you
actually have the test to go on ever if
we can really give a movie audience from
the comfort of their imax cinema the
sense that they've been up that mountain
that would be an incredible thing to do
thanks to movie technology that's part
of the experience of the film
you